good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i am
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2021 2022 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where we'll
enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences our selected participants for
our biomedical data science innovation
lab program will leverage these
presentations as a vital as vital
material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville
virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data
science innovation lab program are being
accepted until january 31st 2022 so
please consider applying and or
encouraging your junior colleagues to do
so we look forward to reviewing their
applications it is my honor and
privilege today to welcome our speaker
dr randall morman is professor of
medicine biomedical engineering and
medical physiology as well as biophysics
bio biological physics here at the
university of virginia randall mormon
was educated at the university of
mississippi and at school of medicine
and trained clinically at duke
university he's been a cardiologist at
uva since 1990 and is the founding
director of the uva center for advanced
medical analytics formerly he was the
chief medical officer of amp 3d a
company which provides extensible
software as a service platforms for
predictive analytics
processing big data from physiological
monitors health records lab tests and
more in real time and at a glance
enabling proactive interventions
improved outcomes and cost savings
throughout a patient's entire hospital
state
emp 3d is now a nihon koden company
as a recent development
in continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme randall's lecture
today is entitled predictive analytics
monitoring at the bedside there's been a
lot of discussion about these days about
how artificial intelligence big data
machine learning and deep learning are
revolutionizing health care by
predicting clinical illnesses like
sepsis and investigators at the uva
center for advanced medical informatics
have been working this area for about 20
years they've gained many insights and
randall is going to share some of that
work with us today make suggestions for
the next generation of researchers
and give pointers for telling what
approaches are most likely to be most
helpful for patients and as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube and if you're
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are
highly encouraged to submit any
questions for dr mormon
by the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i'll synthesize all these
questions and ask them on your behalf at
the last 10 minutes or so of dr norman's
lecture and with that welcome randall we
are so excited to have you um and we're
looking forward to your lecture
well jack thanks very much and i
certainly appreciate the invitation
today i'm going to take the opportunity
to give a narrative account of the long
story of our involvement in predictive
analytics monitoring i'm going to go
back to how how this story all started
it's not something that we revisit much
in our day-to-day work and it was fun
for me to put this talk back together
again aft after some years a couple of
important things on on the
title slide here when i say on behalf of
many i'm not kidding we've been working
in this field for more than 20 years at
uva there aren't enough slides to put
down all the names of people who have
made very significant contributions
along the way i'll point to a couple of
names as i go through but i won't in any
way do justice to the the many works of
the many people that have had their
hands in this
another thing to point out jack has
already mentioned did is that previously
i was the chief medical officer of the
small company in charlottesville that
was spun up out of lice the licensing
adventures group that was acquired over
the summer by a larger company neon
coden which is a japanese maker of
medical monitoring devices and i draw
attention to this because
as
you might guess doing work in a vacuum
or garage can be very gratifying but
only up to a point and to have the kind
of impact on the world that you wish to
have it is imperative that you
understand the commercialization process
and and work in that arena as well and
believe me
the nuances and challenges on the
business side of the things that i'm
going to be talking about are every bit
as complicated and gnarly as the
computers and the mathematics and
especially the clinical excuse me the
clinical issues
involved so so to go back to the
beginning in the 1990s early 1990s i and
the people that i was working with at
the time
thought to ourselves that this is
probably a true statement that there are
detectable signatures of illness
in continuous monitoring data i think
most most clinicians doctors and nurses
that take care of patients would agree
with that that kind of statement as well
but the newness of the idea was that the
detection of these signatures
in real time in real life could change
things by leading to early detection and
early to treat early treatment of
patients with some illnesses and
possibly to improved outcomes and i'll
point to this as being a new idea that
was generated here all that time ago
this new idea like many new ideas went
through an evolution that was first put
forward by the philosopher arthur
schopenhauer that there's three stages
first a new idea or a new truth is
ridiculed second it is violently opposed
and third it is accepted as being
self-evident and this kind of cynical
point of view of the world in fact turns
out to be almost exact i think exactly
correct but we've been gratified to see
that we've made it all the way through
and now everybody generally agrees
with without this idea that early
detection of signatures of illness might
be a good thing didn't used to be that
way in any event we began this story
back in the 1990s working on the problem
of neonatal sepsis that is to say
bloodstream bacterial infection in
premature infants in the neonatal icu
and to say that the diagnosis of this
illness is difficult is a massive
understatement so if if i asked you is
this baby septic your question in return
might be what baby so it turns out that
under this covered crib there does
indeed lie a baby weighing a couple of
pounds maybe three pounds
very hard to understand from from
looking at that patient even when you
get up close and personal
as to whether that that infant is having
symptoms of illness or signs of illness
but sepsis is a bad thing with
potentially catastrophic uh consequences
and so doctors and nurses are forever
wondering about whether their patients
are septic and then doing tests now a
blood draw an adult is no big deal but
to draw two or three cc's of blood from
an infant whose circulating blood volume
is 70 or 80 cc's especially if you want
to draw more than one test well that's a
major consideration about whether or not
to do any tests or not and as as a
result of the suspicion of this
bacterial illness antibiotics are given
a lot to infants at any moment in our
nicu through the years about about a
third of infants at any moment are
receiving antibiotics because of
suspected or proven sepsis so a dire
problem difficult to diagnose is there a
signature of illness well in 1959
i fed i found a paper from 1959 that
that had that pointed in one direction
changes in heart size in the disney
newborn baby well it isn't the hard size
that was interesting in in this paper it
was interesting about it was uh
observations about the heart rate so he
talks here about the the speed of the
heart rate but he makes this this
statement right here a characteristic
finding at the height of respiratory
distress and within a few hours of the
onset of the illness was a fixed rate
between 100 and 10 120 beats a minute
that did not vary if the baby cried or
was roused to physical activity there
follows some nonsense about heart sounds
but then we get down to the bottom here
when they survived early signs of
improvement where a rise in the heart
rate that's fine or a liability of the
rate as shown by variations in it with
exertion so this was a big clue that the
pattern of the heart rates might hold
information at the time that we started
in this
started with this work there was a
decade or so of research into heart rate
variability in adults with heart disease
so this seemed like a likely place to go
looking so sure enough after we figured
out how to make measurements we made
long recordings of ekgs and determined
heart rates from infants in the neonatal
icu and what i'm showing you here is not
a plot of heart rate but a plot of the
times in between
heart beats and so this is upside down
heart rate slow rates up here 500
milliseconds in between beats is a heart
rate of 120 beats per minute
fast heart rates down here 300
milliseconds per heartbeat is a heart
rate of 200
but there's a very there was no matter
how you plot it there's a excuse me a
very striking difference between an
infant at the height of his or her
illness
and after successful recovery yes there
was a bit of a difference in the heart
rate but it is the variation of that
heart rate that is very strikingly
different now it doesn't take a lot of
statistical or mathematical prowess to
be able to tell
that time series from that time series
and and we worked a lot on that but but
just to put some things in context
here's our paper from 1994 and here
we're showing a neural network based on
polynomial nodes to distinguish the
heart rate patterns of the sick baby
from the heart rate patterns of the well
baby so you know neural networks have
been around longer than than than our
work but it
as new as all those techniques might
appear to you to be in point of fact
they're pretty well founded and have
been around for a long time so the
upshot of this was that this particular
technique and other techniques as well
did did a very robust job of
distinguishing babies early in the
course of their illness day one from
after recovery over here and so we we
crystallized our new idea a little bit
better down here at the bottom the new
idea is that the signatures of illness
with respect to neonatal sepsis low
heart rate variability and so we set out
to find out more about that and when we
fashioned tools to make long recordings
and actually look at the ekg signal here
a few heartbeats from from an infant up
here and then rather longer time series
of the time in between heartbeats here
and we knew what was happening with the
infants and so we could match what we
knew clinically with what our eye told
us about the patterns here so this is
what normal neonatal heart rate
variability looks like over about a 25
minute stretch of time and ekg
aficionados will note that this is sinus
rhythm which is essentially the only
heart rhythm that the newborn infants
have they aren't really plagued by
cardiac arrhythmias okay so here's an
infant who was several hours before the
clinical diagnosis of sepsis that is to
say baby for all intents and purposes
was clinically fine but a few hours from
now is going to be diagnosed with with
that dire illness
and so what what about our new idea
about reduced heart rate variability
well okay well sure enough
through here here's a stretch of 10
minutes or something of heart rate
variability this certainly lower than
what i just showed you a second ago but
lo and behold here are these other
things now this is still the time
between heartbeats so from time to time
there are some long intervals that is to
say that the heart slows down some
during during these times it's a very
striking looking thing to look at a flat
line with spikes going up in it this is
to say that the rhythm remains sinus
rhythm that is to say normal rhythm here
we are same baby a little bit later
and now this is very strikingly
different from normal and yes if you
look if you can find a quiet baseline
the variability is very much different
what than what i showed you before but
here are deceleration after deceleration
after deceleration now the heart the the
bradycardia alarm is at about the top of
the screen so i'm showing you some very
pronounced examples ones that would have
in fact triggered the alarm at the
bedside but that's not always the case
and here are some perfectly good
decelerations over here that got nowhere
near the alarm threshold and there were
many many of these as well in what we
looked at those of you interested in
cardiac electrophysiology what's
happening is these are sinus pauses
there's no evidence for overt sinus exit
block there's no evidence for av nodal
slowing the mechanism of this as much as
i like to think i know about this kind
of thing is not totally known to me but
the phenomenology
is blindingly clear here now we set out
to to get mathematical measures to
distinguish these things i'm sorry
here's here's another example may have
been this example in fact so heart rate
variability a week before the diagnosis
of sepsis this is about a 25 minute
record here a few hours before here the
the the bradycardia alarm would be way
up here and then as as before the
perfectly storming
appearance of heart rate decelerations
against this backdrop of reduced
variability so our methods for
quantifying this we're centered around
the idea that the histograms of the of
the heartbeat intervals would look
different between the normal and
abnormal episodes and so if you conceive
of a normal record here is one as being
composed of many small accelerations
this again is time between heartbeats
along with many small decelerations
then the histogram turns out to be
if not exactly gaussian at least
certainly bell-shaped with
representations on both sides of the
median so looked at in this way the
abnormal record
presents itself as a very abnormal
looking histogram so here are the
decelerations here and so now there's a
fat tail on this part of the histogram
and i hadn't drawn attention to it
previously but the accelerations have
all been clipped off and so the half of
the histogram that reflects
accelerations is truncated on that side
now some of you may have been reflecting
upon the fact that this heart rate
pattern reduced variability and
decelerations is precisely the pattern
that clinicians that are delivering
babies on the on the in the labor and
delivery suite are looking for in the
heart rate patterns of the fetus and
this idea reduced variability with
decelerations
is a mantra up there that it's time to
do an emergent emergency cesarean
section that is a time honored practice
100 of fetuses are monitored in that way
in the bigger hospital certainly it's
true at our hospital and cesarean
sections are the decisions are made
based on picking up strips of paper from
the floor eyeballing it looking for this
pattern and then saying go so it
shouldn't be surprising that that a a
premature infant who by rights should
still have been a fetus inside a uterus
should show distress with the same kind
of heart rate patterns now as part of
working
on this we we got involved with the idea
of measuring entropy of in these heart
rate time series this is too long a
story to go into now but suffice it to
say that that entropy in this domain
from the non-linear dynamical uh
domain which is where we borrowed the
concept is a matter of looking for
repeating patterns and so in short as we
examine this time series we look for
patterns that repeat themselves
tolerably well and let's just say that
this we're interested in this pair of
green points and as we scan everywhere
else we find a tolerably similar other
pair of green points and now the
question is does the point that follows
the red point also match from the
original over into here and the more
that that is true that is to say the
more to the more truth there is to the
idea that patterns repeat themselves
suggest that that the system is of low
entropy in the sense that it's not
generating new information
as it goes along now after that there
there are some excuse me some details
about how you count things and how you
calculate things and we we uh found some
difficulties with with a current
measurement and we developed our own
that we called sample entropy and that
went on to become something unto itself
but is a good example of the kind of
time series mathematics that we have
used so through the years we we have
kept ourselves busy with adapting and
optimizing and developing
new or new to the area mathematical time
series measures and this is a sort of a
narrative account of
some number of them and i'll be coming
back to the last one the most recent one
um in a little bit sample entropy went
on to become a kind of a one-stop shop
for chaos theory in all fields uh
at all times and and and
gathered some popularity
okay so the way that we we put together
our mathematical measures was using
logistic regression and i'm sure you're
familiar with that from the the modern
discussions of machine learning and deep
learning that to do this you need a set
of data from infants that aren't sick
you need another set of data from
infants r or at the time that they are
you label one set of data's outcome
equals zero you label the other outcome
as outcome outcome equals one and then
you model the log odds of the event as a
straight line as as a co coefficients
times variables plus an intercept and
you end up by the time you back out the
probability with this familiar
expression here where you have
exponentiated versions of a linear
combination of variables and those of
you that remember y equals mx plus b
well that's exactly what this is here is
the intercept here is the slope here is
the variable it's multivariable so so
you can put more of these things in
there and when all was said and done we
based our index on four measures that we
got from the time series the standard
deviation because sometimes the the long
records were quiet throughout
two measures from the histogram the
acceleration based measure and the
deceleration based measure and this and
this entropy thing that i'm talking been
telling you about so we
fit our logistic regression model
with all of our data and came out with a
measure that we could show clinicians
that reflected to them the probability
of sepsis in the next 24 hours now
rather than give them a
give the clinicians a probability as
such we gave that gave them the fold
increase in the probability of the event
with respect to average thus and a
normal infant hanging out in the
neonatal icu should have a score of one
or less average risk or lower than
average risk an advantage to using this
this unit of measurements which we have
stuck with ever since is that it makes
for english language discussions about
what
what the measure means so if i tell you
that this score is two that means your
infant is twice as likely as average to
have an event and clinicians can
resonate with this this kind of thinking
so i'm showing you here 14 day records
from two of the infants this is from a
paper in 2003. we're up to there now
um showing you every six hour
measurements of this score um on their
in infants on their way to to having
having the diagnosis of sepsis and the
the diagnosis of sepsis on this timeline
is denoted by this acronym crash which
stands for cultures resuscitation and
antibiotics started here and what you
can see from this is in both of these
cases that we selected there were waves
of increase of this score over the days
and days prior but there was certainly
evidence for increased risk prior to
events now the this score doesn't happen
in a vacuum there are a lot of other
things happening to that infant in the
way of being on ventilatory support or
having central lines drugs other
measurements that people are making
laboratory tests and and so forth and so
my colleague doug lake with whom i
worked closely since 2001 or two
started making these things that we have
called event maps that place on one
visualization
the presence and the severity of
abnormality of events and measurements
during the hospital stay
and superimposed is this score here we
call it the hrc index it's also called
the hero score but that here here it
sits and here are its units over to the
side and this was a very this is a very
typical looking one where blood cultures
were drawn here antibiotics were given
here the diagnosis of sepsis was made
here other things were going on in the
way of tachycardia and temperature
instability and whatnot and here's a
gratifying rise in the hero score prior
to the clinical diagnosis and this is
the spirit of the use of predictive
analytics monitoring at the bedside if a
patient has a low risk that rises
then it makes sense to us for clinicians
to go see that patient and evaluate that
patient in the light of there is
possibly a subacute potentially
catastrophic illness on its way so about
this time we
applied for and were issued a patent for
the for this idea of early diagnosis of
subacute potentially catastrophic
illness and i draw attention to this
simply because it is the first step
along the commercialization pathway no
company will undertake to manufacture
and distribute something that is in the
public domain i'm sorry that's true i
didn't invent that but that that is the
hard truth of the matter and so the
commercial product that came out is this
which is the hero monitor it has run
continuously in the uva neonatal icu
since the spring of 2000 and uh since
the fall of 2003
when it when it got its first fda 510k
clearance and and this is the spirit of
it here here is a low score it's less
than one here it has gone up at this
vertical yellow line here are the 30
minutes of heart rate that were present
at that time here is reduced variability
here are decelerations it is a very
robust and repeatable and repeating
signature of illness in that population
and since this since we're talking about
history that this is the first so far as
i know premature infant who was
diagnosed with sepsis without having any
clinical illness to go along with it so
this was within the first week or two of
putting the hero monitor up in the uva
nicu here we are over 10 days and here
goes the score nicely less than one
until it wasn't and it rose to a value
of something over two
here are the heart rate records that go
with it here we are a week prior let's
call that normal here we are at the time
of of interest
reduced variability decelerations no
great change in the heart rate and then
here we are after the fact back to
normal again so what happened was that
the the clinicians taking care of this
infant knew the story looked up on the
wall saw an increase in the hero score
and undertook two to evaluate the
patient for sepsis so they looked at the
baby no no clinical signs of illness
they drew the usual suspect laboratories
all of them were normal except for one
they sent a sample of blood to the
microbiology lab and and asked for it to
be cultured and sure enough 12 hours
later they received a call to say that
the blood was growing a gram-negative
organism seratian marscessons now the
death rate in the nicu from seratia
sepsis is on the order of 40
4 out of 10 infants with with this
diagnosis
die as a result of it
in this case they got the blood culture
result back they could not ignore it
they started antibiotics hero score came
down and
the baby not only didn't die
the baby never got sick
now that is a remarkable
event an an infant who contracts an
acute infectious
systemic illness where the death rate is
4 out of 10
but it is diagnosed at a time so early
that they have not become ill
and rece and further receives
appropriate therapy on the spot the
entire illness was averted that is a
wonderful story this galvanized all of
this that work in this field i got
chills when they called me from the nicu
and told me about it i get chills
telling it to you today it is a
remarkable
realization of the potential of what we
can do with data from patients to
improve outcomes now what i've just told
you is is is a great story but it is it
is oh let me let me go ahead to say that
we looked at more patients that had this
kind of event that is to say a large
abrupt increase in the hrc index or hero
score
and what we found was that fully half of
them had an infection
excuse me infection that required
treatment so this is the positive
predictive value it's 50 percent
if you haven't dealt with positive
predictive values for rare events let me
explain let me tell you that's a big
number
um in in contrast the positive predicted
value from my clinical world of a
treadmill test where everything goes
wrong with the patient that possibly
could go wrong the positive predictive
value of that finding for a heart attack
in the next year is about 10
so this this positive predictive value
of 48 is a very big number indeed other
infants that had this finding had other
kinds of illnesses um and we were
reassured from this that that was not a
one-time occurrence
so to further hammer home the question
or answer the question of whether this
is going to
help others
and we undertook a randomized clinical
trial
so this became by the time it was over
the largest randomized trial ever
undertaken in premature infants
i beg your point for this or any other
reason 3 000 infants of less than 1500
grams birth weight were randomized in
nine neonatal icus up and down the east
coast and the randomization was
extremely simple um once the infant got
there and the parents signed consent we
either
assigned them to have this risk shown to
clinicians or to receive only standard
of care and not have it displayed there
were no mandated interventions no one
had to look at the monitor let alone
report on it let alone act on it there
were 3 000 infants more than 100 doctors
more than a thousand nurses the primary
outcome measure had to do was a it
remains a popular
sepsis related outcome and we had other
outcome measures in particular in
hospital mortality now the big result
from this trial was in one of the other
outcome measures and that was that there
was decreased mortality that is to say
improved survival when we showed the
risk display to clinicians these are
survival curves over the 120 days after
randomization that the trial was
designed to inspect
here is the survival of infants
receiving conventional monitoring their
mortality
that you're part of their mortality over
120 days was little more than 10
which is exactly as expected from u.s
national statistics the mortality from
the infants received who had the new
monitoring was eight and a bit percent a
relative reduction of something more
than twenty percent so twenty percent
improved survival from turning on a
computer screen and showing it to the
people taking care of the baby i'm not
going to show you the results but we
went on to show that the the survival
benefit was very heavily concentrated in
the infants who got septic where the
survival where the mortality rate fell
from 20 percent with conventional
monitoring by almost half to 12
in the infants that that had the
predictive monitoring as well so this is
a a a
a wonderful result the paper was
published 10 years ago
as far as i know it remains the largest
randomized trial of
of this kind it will be superseded next
year when we complete a similar trial
that's currently going on in our
cardiology award okay so that that is
was a flagship finding in the field and
as galvanized as i say us to continue to
do other work and now something let me
give you some examples of of that kind
of thing as well but i'll return at the
end to to the to the infants again okay
so this is logistic regression we have
used other kinds of machine learning we
are dabbling our toe into deep learning
at this point
but one interesting finding that's
representative i think of the kinds of
findings that that an exploration of
different kinds of machine learning will
bring out is how different statistical
models
view important variables in the clinical
population so this is a very this is a
small segment of a bunch of results from
a similar study not a randomized trial
but a study that we did in the pediatric
icu
where the range of age goes from 0 to 18
years and we were interested again in
the question of sepsis and again we use
predictive models so what what i'm
showing you here is is how the method uh
how the methodology can lead to
differences in the way that the the
variables are treated or looked at in
the overall statistical model now so
here is the this is the plot of the log
of the odds as a function of the age of
the patient in the pediatric icu down in
the footnotes we're using restricted
cubic splines to get away from the fact
that this would have to be a monotonic
straight line and this is the story here
okay and this these this is the
analytical result that comes back from
the fitted model but over here we used a
random forest model and we were struck
by the difference in how age was treated
when you could look at it in this much
much much more granular kind of way
using random forest methodology and it
resonated clinically with those with the
doctors up there that they felt that
this represented better what they
thought about and that is that infants
in the knee closer to the neonatal
period had the highest risk in in their
unit not the finding after you do the
cubic spline kind of approach but very
much the finding over here if you let
the data drive the model
now
as i've said we have moved on beyond the
nicu and in point of fact we have found
that there are signatures of illness
everywhere i'm showing you results here
from a few years ago in a large study
that we conducted in our surgical icu
and our medical icu and we threw in nicu
results over here as well but this was
to this was to establish the idea that
the signatures of different illnesses
might differ from each other and so here
i'm showing you what i'm calling a
signature of illness i'm going to draw
attention to two of the colored tiles to
explain what i'm talking about each of
these is a plot of the law of gods as a
function of the measured variable and
they all come from multi-variable
logistic regression models and these log
odds plots are from the multi-variable
model that is to say these are the
associated odds of of the illness given
all of the other variables are in the
model at the same time the way to
interpret these kinds of plots are for
example this one which i've brought over
and expanded over here this is to say
that the odds of
emergency intubation in the surgical icu
go up as the mean respiratory rate goes
up patients that are breathing faster
are at higher risk of requiring
emergency intubation not a stunning
effect but that's that is the truth of
the matter so the this is colored orange
because the risk increases as the
variable as the measured variable
increases and it's deeply huge because
the p value was very low here's the
counter example we're now talking about
bleeding also in the surgical icu and
we're looking at the diastolic blood
pressure this is blown up over here as
the diastolic blood pressure is lower
the risk of the event goes up bleeding
leads to low blood pressure we all knew
that coming in not a surprise but this
is
but these are what i mean when you put
them together by signatures of illness
and the way you analyze this is you go
stand across the room you look at the
respiratory models and you say to
yourself yes those look pretty similar
from what one adult icu to the next and
then you stand across the room and you
look at the hemorrhage models and you
say yes they look pretty similar from
what one adult icu to the next but wait
a minute so here's sepsis now in adults
the signatures of illness do not look
like each other they look different in
point of fact in the in the medical icu
sepsis presents more like hemorrhage and
the surgical icu sepsis presents more
like lung failure here's the neonatal
icu all of the signatures look the same
same diagnoses
but now they look they all look
exactly like each other and none of them
look anything like that like what
happens to adults so this is to make the
point that illnesses
in populations in hospital settings have
signatures that can differ from place to
place it's a strong argument against
using a single predictive model
everywhere and so when we go to to
introduce predictive monitoring
somewhere every unit has its own models
every target illness has its own as well
so i'm going to take you now to
oh i'm sorry now just one moment
i'm going to take you now to
what what we are currently doing in the
icu's about displaying risk uh to
clinicians about patients what you're
looking at here is a comet monitor
35
of beds at the university of virginia
hospital have real-time predictive
monitoring some of those are the nicu
and i've already shown you that the rest
of them have this thing that we call as
i say we call the comet plot and i'm
showing you now results from the uh from
old uh de-identified data real data real
patients i have no idea who and i
actually have no idea when these data
were collected either
so for this unit we we elected to show
the clinicians the risk of sepsis again
fold increase one two three four five
and also in hospital mortality and so
what we're showing you is every bed in
the picu the bed number is shown in the
head of this structure we call them
comets because they look like comets the
tail of the comet is three hours long
so if you were an attending physician in
the pediatric icu and you walked in and
saw this
one use case is that you don't stop
walking and you just direct your feet to
beds 91 c 92 or 96 to see what is going
on
in there you don't go in there armed
with a diagnosis or a medication or a
plan your attention is drawn to those
because they are at high risk and in
some cases increasing risk
the the the system is set up in such a
way that you can isolate a single
patient and look back over time to see
is this a new problem or a chronic
problem or how just exactly how long has
all of this been going on and as i say
we have this available for a lot of
units inside the hospital and this is
our current incarnation current
application for um how we show the
clinicians uh what is going on with
their patients based on on the data that
are streaming in now these estimates are
based not only on the ekg time series
that that i showed you before but
actually everything that comes from the
bedside monitor which includes o2
saturations blood pressures
are arterial waveforms if they're
present and in addition we also use
everything that's in the ehr laboratory
tests and vital signs most systems of
this kind restrict themselves to what's
in the ehr there's some theoretical
problems with that but we we use them
too and we add like i say the real time
continuous aspect to it as as well so
let me go back to sharing here
i'm sorry i beg your pardon that's not
what i wanted
let me go back to presenting here
okay so in our surgical icu which is
where we put the first of these displays
in 2015 we counted heads in the six
months before and the six months after
turning it on and we were interested in
outcomes there not a randomized trial
but was there an impact of outcomes and
the the the major result was that the
rate of septic shock so this is sepsis
plus severe hypotension
fell by half after we turned on the
display in the medical icu nearby where
there was no display the incidence of
septic shock remained much the same
there were some improvements and some
other outcomes it was a fairly large
study but this was the only one to reach
statistical significance it remains
statistically significant
after taking age and illness severity
into account as well so good
justification for further randomized
trials such as the one that i mentioned
earlier
now i'm coming back let me come back to
and finish with with an observation
about where where all of this started
this is recent work um and a very high
personal interest so all those years ago
we we based it all all everything that
has happened subsequently started when
we looked at this and said this is a
signature of sepsis in premature infants
and now this is not a question we asked
ourselves back then and i'm glad we
didn't but looking back it's it's
interesting to think about how did we
know that that was true
and now here's here's a modern question
having asked that question how do you
even begin to figure out
whether you knew you were right or not
okay so enter a enter a technique called
highly comparative time series analysis
so in 2013 doug lake who might who i
should have mentioned before um reviewed
a paper with with that title and for the
next several years was telling me what a
good idea this was and after a number of
those years it had finally it finally
sunk in what he was talking about we set
forth together to try with others to try
to figure something out highly
comparative time series analysis
what is involved is or what it was in
this paper was the investigators took
several thousand time series from all
sorts of origins that they were able to
find
geology
medicine
astrology anything that they could find
large time series and then did numerical
calculations on them they call them
operations using a very large number
thousands in fact of different kinds of
mathematical operations and when they
come out of it they have millions of
results and they've used here rna arrays
uh
sequence rna arrays
to visualize the kinds of results so
this is a massively comprehensive
characterization of
time series on a scale
that it took me a long time to
understand what what they were even
talking about but with with doug and
with tim clark who in the school of data
science and school of public health we
managed to to get this done
so here are the the the families of
mathematical operations a description
and some examples and we had amongst all
of these things
2500 numerical algorithms that we could
apply to time series we applied them to
two sets of time series the heart rate
and the oxygen saturation in each time
series was 300 points long so this is a
massive simply massive amount of of
computation
so
there i'm leaving out some of the
intermediary results to take you to the
result that was most directly relevant
to to the point that i brought up so
here is a zoom call from octa from a
year ago
and on the call or myself karen
fairchild who's a clinical neonatologist
and the engine for neonatology research
in our group over the past five years
and more
justin niestroy a former math major at
the university of virginia now and also
master's degree in data science from the
the university of virginia at the time
working in the group of tim clark tim
drinking that doesn't happen often but
there he is drinking and here is doug
lake here and the the result here is not
so consequential but it gives me a
chance to say what we did so out of all
those algorithms we were able to turn to
determine those that were the best at
characterizing
neonatal heart rate and oxygen
saturation time series that is to say we
used an unsupervised clustering
technique and derived from it two dozen
measures that were that that as i say
covered the waterfront for
characterizing the dynamics and the
distributions of heart rate on one hand
and oxygen saturation on the other hand
time series so we're now armed with a
way to look at all possible patterns of
neonatal heart rate
so what we did was we took those two
dozen
descriptors of
neonatal heart rate dynamics and
prepared a logistic regression model on
the patients that were septic and then
we inspected the results with resp with
regard to
what records did this new approach think
were associated with the highest risk of
sepsis in the next 24 hours and lo and
behold here they are these are 300 point
heart rate time series records
discovered
using an unsupervised clustering method
and then the results of that in a
logistic regression model on sepsis and
look what we have reduced variability
and decelerations these are the top 16
riskiest records out of a very very
large data set here we have doug
drinking and karen i didn't know she was
doing this but that was the first time i
saw this and it hit me like a ton of
bricks that this was the answer to the
question how did we when how did we know
we were on the right track i don't know
but i but i am assured of that by this
very comprehensive mathematical analysis
coming up with exactly the same result
so this is a figure that that i made
when the model predicting sepsis using
results of an unsupervised clustering
technique predicted highest risk reduced
variability decelerations when the model
predicted lowest risk high variability
accelerations and then these two records
are at about the 50th percentile in the
75th percentile or something like that
they are of diminishing risk as as we
move across um like that
now the this
there ends the most of what i want to
say
about what we used to call statistical
pattern recognition what we now call
machine learning big data artificial
intelligence all the other things that
that you know about let me say that in
in the in this field the new frontier is
understanding what to do with this
information and so i've listed a to-do
list of things that that begins with
framing the clinical questions that are
of of importance to doctors and nurses
and ending with figuring out how to get
it distributed and and i will tell you
every step along that pathway we have we
have
we have stumbled fallen sometimes picked
ourselves up sometimes not but this is
what is required to get from point from
point a to point z
in this field i'm ending with this
picture which is a photograph that i
took more than 10 years ago
of our group at work and it's to make
the point that this is not a job for
some person in isolation that this
requires a
multi-disciplinary team of people
working on it and this was not this is
obviously not rehearsed or opposed or
staged or any of those things but just
to point out some people this is john
catwinkel
for many years the director of the of
neonatology here and in
a world eminence in that field karen
fairchito fairchild i've already pointed
out before hoshik lee is a is a phd
physicist was the postdoctoral fellow of
john the loss distinguished professor of
physics at william and mary matthew
clark at the time was a postdoctoral
fellow he's he was then the chief
science officer at amped and he's now
principal engineer and nihon
coden brooke vergales is a clinical
neonatologist as is rob sinkin not shown
in this in this picture is doug lake
but there's very much this picture very
very much this idea of a committed
collaborative group of clinical doctors
and quantitative scientists or data
scientists
come together to communicate across a
wide gap to address a problem that's of
importance to patients and their
families and the people that take care
of them at the bedside with that i'll
stop talking i'd be delighted to answer
questions and thanks again for the
invitation
randall thank you so much for what an
engaging talk that was really wonderful
and i was um i i love that you've ended
on this notion of team science it really
does take a village especially when it's
a very practical problem of that you're
trying to address and
even in those cases where it's a
practical problem is that these things
aren't simple and you need experts from
a number of different domains to be able
to address them
um i have a couple of questions for us
to to get you kind of started um so um
you mentioned that these a lot of this
work comes from uh devices that sit at
the bedside of various patients and i'm
kind of curious if you explored like
putting this on to say taking it out of
the away from the bedside and into the
community for example like on a smart
watch could something like this be
something that somebody could have
running on their iphone watch and you
know be a sound an alarm should you know
somebody's heart rate uh
descend into some degree of you know the
wrong end of the entropy spectrum if you
know what i mean well so there's several
interesting pieces of that um and
many of which we have not not touched on
i consider the the ambulatory monitoring
problem
to be every bit as big or bigger than
the in hospital the impa hospital
inpatient
problem
recall that i pointed out as we went by
that the positive predictive value that
is to say the probability that an alarm
is a true alarm
it inevitably falls as the
as the rarity of the event increases and
so if you're out there monitoring
everyone for things that don't happen
very often the very very great majority
of alarms are going to be false alarms
now this is being tested out there
because they're atrial fibrillation
detection algorithms built into apple
watches now and there are other ways
other other kinds of things as well
and
atrial fibrillation very important
clinical diagnosis calls for
you know in intensive treatments um and
i'm very interested to see how how all
of that is going going to work out i
must say i don't have any personal
interest in going after that market um
because of i think the diff the false
alarm difficulty is going to be very
high
so the other aspect of this that that i
wanted to comment on is the whole idea
of alarms in the first place so if you
know that alarms are going to be false i
i wouldn't issue them it
the inpatient story is very much attuned
to the idea that you're looking for
changes in risk people come in sick they
should get better people get better they
should stay better they shouldn't get
sick again and so the whole thinking of
the clinical team is
very much are they okay are they are
they okay are they okay and the nicu
it's
are they separate card they said big are
they septic so the idea that you've got
something in real time or it's refreshes
every 15 minutes or an hour or whatever
but in reasonable real time that's
keeping you abreast of current events
and somebody that you know an awful lot
about that resonates strongly with me as
a clinician as a useful thing to do much
more so than than the ambulatory one you
mentioned uh a fibrillation and uh you
know one of the uh
big risks with people who are an afib is
an increased risk of stroke and i'm
curious if you've uh you mentioned eye
watches have this capability in them now
i'm curious if you've attempted to apply
this to looking at afib patients and
their risk of stroke for example in
contrast to sepsis in in neonates
you know afib predicting stroke in
cardiac patients for example
well there are steps in that direction
have been toward improved
identification of atrial fibrillation
from inpatient data from the inpatient
ekg telemetry so we did this work a few
years ago we have you know we
applied our time series interest towards
this it's not the hardest thing in the
world to diagnose and it's foiled by a
few things like premature beats but we
worked hard on this and developed what i
think is a very nice algorithm for
detection of atrial fibrillation given
an ekg
recording so we went back in our records
and and found that there was a lot of
undiagnosed atrial fibrillation in our
intensive care units in fact about half
of the atrial fibrillation that occurred
in the icu
in patients that didn't have it when
they walked in and weren't already you
know on the radar but about half of the
new atrial fibrillation in the ic use
was not not commented on or acted upon
by clinicians and so to the end of
detecting atrial fibrillation so as to
to
start earlier diagnosis and therapy that
that is a great idea our bandwidth is
not extended clinically to be able to do
something about that although i think
that picture may may be changing soon in
in uh with regard to
uh detect or detection of the risk of
stroke we've not taken that additional
step we're at the find the atrial
fibrillation part later would come in
larger studies did it how to what extent
was atrial fibrillation related to
stroke the real question and i think
this actually got addressed i think
recently is if you do all of that and
then randomize patients to blood
thinners which is of course the stroke
prevention
step that you take if you
give them ambulatory atrial fibrillation
detection devices and when atrial
fibrillation is diagnosed randomize them
to blood thinner or no is there an
impact on the stroke rate there's a
recent study that had no that had a
negative result and said the stroke rate
was the same i don't know everything i
need to know about that but that at
least is the is the ultimate design or
that is the design of the study to
answer the ultimate question that you
just that you know the way that you've
brought it up
what do you think some of the current or
kind of like
just more immediate challenges exist
what are some longer term challenges
that need to be overcome and where can
data science continue to play a role
i well the two things so so
my advice to the to the young data
scientists is go find a young clinician
who is obsessed
with a clinical problem for which early
detection
might lead to therapies that can improve
outcomes and
you will be
codependent clinicians are too busy to
go do all of the programming required
programmers
do not have their hands around the
nuances and complexities of
of clinical medicine i'll say with
specific regard to
machine learning models in health care
there's a there's i have a lot of
questions these days and i mentioned
this going through about relying only on
the electronic health record as a source
of data and the reason for that is that
it very much reflects in addition to the
patient and the illness it very much
reflects the clinician and the health
system and the decisions that they make
the diagnoses that they're entertaining
and the policies of the hospital so
imagine that
that what a patient it is admitted to
the hospital with shortness of breath
and an abnormal chest x-ray one
clinician might very reasonably think
well this is decompensated heart failure
and order blood tests and medications
that relate to that another clinician
might also reasonably make the diagnosis
of pneumonia and go off on a completely
different attack now the the data that
those clinicians gather will be very
different from each from one from the
other because of their
their diagnosis or their assist their
working diagnosis and so they'll be
investigating different aspects
of the patient and the idea that you
have colorized the patient and filled in
all the dots on the invisible man so
that you can now make out that form
distinctly is is just is just not right
it doesn't work that way and so i worry
about
approaches you that use only ehr because
of incompleteness inaccuracy and and
this is supposed to be about ethical and
equitable ai believe me there are issues
about the way patients get worked up in
hospitals based on their race and
ethnicity and that will
inevitably play into the data sets that
you have to analyze
that brings me to kind of a final
question is are there communities in the
us or internationally where a technology
like this might be really helpful for
addressing things like for example
infant mortality rates
well i i
i think that a harder question would be
is there a hospital in the u.s that
doesn't need to figure out some way to
use all the data that they've got on
their patients absolutely individualized
predictions um i
again now would that change the infant
mortality rate of the u.s i don't know
how to answer that would it change the
mortality rate of premature infants and
neonatal icus in the u.s
without question there's a large
randomized trial that says exactly that
that's fantastic well with that randall
thank you so much we really appreciate
you sharing with us this uh important
work that uh you're doing and have been
doing and the the work of your team uh
you are a good representative of uh all
their efforts and uh thank you so much
for contributing to our seminar series
um
everyone uh thank you so much for for
taking part and everyone have a great
weekend and we'll look forward to seeing